[Musik]
hallo zusammen es ist Kürbiszeit und ich
habe mir gedacht dieses Jahr fahre ich
richtig auf ich mache richtig fancy
Kürbisrezepte und heute gibt es Risotto
mit Kürbis könnt ihr dann auch wahlweise
ohne Kürbis machen falls ihr das Rezept
mal zu einem anderen Zeitpunkt aufruft
und es geht super easy Risotto ist ja
richtig cremiger Reis und wir fangen
jetzt aber erstmal an mit dem
Kürbispüree das muss man vorbereiten
dafür einen halben Hokkaido Kürbis
einfach aushöhlen schälen und für 10
Minuten im Wasser kochen und
anschließend pürieren
[Musik]
so eigentlich ist das wirklich ein
einfaches und schnelles Rezept nur ein
paar Kleinigkeiten müssen wir jetzt
vorbereiten ich habe jetzt zum Beispiel
ganz heißes Wasser genommen hauptsache
es ist jetzt nicht kalt damit es nicht
recht kalt in die heiße Masse kommt und
gibt da jetzt Gemüsebrühe mit rein das
ist dann einfach schon mal vorbereitet
und denkt dran je nachdem welche
Gemüsebrühe ihr verwendet einige sind ja
schon sehr salzig meine jetzt nicht so
müsst dann nachher mit dem Salz
aufpassen ich mache euch zwei mal
genauer Angaben aber dennoch schmeckt
bitte immer wieder zwischendurch ab so
was ich jetzt auch schon vorbereite ist
meine Zwiebel schön fein hacken und
Knoblauchzehen werde ich auch schon mal
fein hacken
[Musik]
jetzt stehe ich hier am Herd und gebe
etwas Olivenöl auf den Topfboden und
werde jetzt zwiebeln und Knoblauch für
ungefähr zwei Minuten darin andünsten
und anschließend gebe ich den
Risottoreis dazu den diesmal nicht
waschen in Einwand Reis Rezepten sage
ich waschen aber diesmal wollen wir dass
der ein bisschen
schlotziger wird im positiven Sinne also
nicht waschen
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt hier noch getrocknete
Tomaten reingegeben bzw bei mir war es
jetzt eher eine getrocknete Tomatenpaste
wenn ihr getrocknete Tomaten aus dem
Glas verwendet dann einfach richtig
schön fein hacken und mit dazugeben das
passt jetzt einfach geschmacklich super
und gibt auch noch eine schöne Farbe ab
und das hättet ihr auch schon zu den
Zwiebeln mitgeben können was falls er so
ein spontanes Ding bei mir und jetzt
geben wir Gemüsebrühe mit rein und zwar
immer peua pö also so viel bis der
Risotto Reis gerade so bedeckt ist und
dann gelegentlich umrühren damit auch
nichts anpappt und dann anschließend
immer wieder was nachgießen das heißt
ihr solltet jetzt eigentlich immer am
Herd stehen bleiben
[Musik]
also immer wenn das Wasser verdampft und
Ihr einfach kein Wasser mehr seht kommt
wieder ein Schluck Wasser rein und zwar
so viel bis der Reis grad so bedeckt ist
und dann steht ihr wieder hier und das
Ganze also dieser ganze Prozess dauert
so 15 bis 20 Minuten und ihr könnt auch
dann ganz zum Schluss schon euer
Kürbispüree dazugeben wenn es weglassen
wollt dann wäre das Risotto so schon
fast fertig aber ich verfeiner gleich
noch mit Parmesankäse und Butter
[Musik]
so mit meiner goldenen Schaufel Schaufel
ich mich jetzt durch das Risotto und
gucke ob noch Salz und Pfeffer fehlen
hmm boah lecker boah ich habe noch vor
dem Dreh zur Sarah gesagt bin jetzt
nicht der Größte kürbisfan aber das
schmeckt echt gut diese kürbisnote die
passt perfekt eigentlich brauche ich nur
noch minimal ein bisschen Salz und ein
bisschen Pfeffer und dann ist es fertig
ich freue mich ich kann hier am Ende
einfach nur noch mit Kürbiskernöl das
passt ja perfekt vielleicht gebe ich
noch ja ich gebe noch Petersilie mit
dazu für ein bisschen Grün einfach für
die Optik und ihr könnt auch Kürbiskerne
mit dazu geben also optisch kriegt auf
jeden Fall schon mal zehn von zehn und
geschmacklich auch
gegessen gerade also ich habe gerade
Kekse gegessen falls Ihr hier was
gesehen haben
[Musik]
Leute ich bin im siebten risotto-himmel
schmeckt so gut ich wusste schon dass es
schmecken wird aber ich dachte ja es
wird mir solide 8 von zehn zehn von zehn
also diese kürbisnutte macht es richtig
rund ich mache natürlich auch klassisch
mit so richtig es darf halt auch nicht
zu pampig schmecken das ist ja gar nicht
der Fall man darf auch nicht unendlich
viel umrühren also immer gelegentlich
dann wird es auch nicht pampig
parmesanbrot reingepasst Butter macht's
nochmal rund und ansonsten wünsche ich
Euch ganz viel Freude beim Nachmachen
und wir sehen uns dann beim nächsten
Video tschüss
[Musik]